donkeys booty bites last fighter
standing brought to you by audible oh my
god are you guys in for a treat
March mania continues
snicker it is and as the opener just
said this is last fighter standing guys
I'm here and then I'm here on this cuts
of the yjt look I'm here by myself
because we have this is gonna be a
rotating panel of fighters and we have
them over the other room can we cut and
show look at this rad team over here
will be fighting us cutting - oh there
they are
oh my gosh some of our best fighters of
all time are all together and they're
all gonna be fighting here on last
fighter standing guys I'm so excited to
do this I want to hype this up before I
even introduce how this is gonna work
because I should have done that better
they're all fighting and coveting for
this this is the showstopper and guys
the showstopper will be revealed what
the power of the showstopper is will be
revealed at the end the show but the
winner of this guy of this prize guys I
cannot hit amp this up more this will
change movie fights forever do you guys
get it you want to win the showstopper I
promise the winner of this could change
the game forever so you do not want to
miss your opportunity once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to win the showstopper at
the end of the show the winner will be
able to open and will know what this is
or will talk about what this means so
stay tuned you will not want to miss
this now guys at home you've been
helping us vote we sent out tweets we
knew we wanted to seed this properly and
it wanted you to help give your favorite
fighters the advantage to hopefully win
this fight because they're gonna want to
win this fight so we did our tweets we
sent them all out thank you guys off for
tweeting and the Twitter the standings
came out and this is how it's going to
work the most popular most retweeted
people are going to be going last the
ones who didn't are going to go first
and the way this works is three people
will come up the eighth seed the seventh
seed the sixth seed and the loser will
go back to the couches is out of the
game the fifth seed will then join us
and so on so every time you got to stand
here and you got to fight as long as you
can if you're in the last place you're
out the first and second places will win
this is sort of a different way to judge
for me because I'm going to basically be
judging who gave the worst argument and
they're out of here and they're out they
can't come back in guys on the couches
does that make sense does everyone
understand this games going to work
not at all whatsoever it'll hopefully
make sense see how all right let's
introduce who's going to start this
fight because we have some really fun
tailor-made fights for each of you
first up in the 8th seed its mark and
red go mark come on - come on down
you're the first contestant oh there he
is
welcome mark next up in the seventh seed
it's Scott movie mass Wow is iconic here
he comes
passion oh my gosh and in the seventh or
sorry sixth seed JT come back here come
back here not so fast
I'm sorry I don't mean to derail to show
this this early but I have something I
getting off my chest here alright Dan go
for it soul searching these people on
Twitter that say you have defend your
belts enough you don't fight hard enough
you're no champion you don't you don't
take the hard fight you don't take the
hard road you always go the easy route
you know and I'm the number one seed
here today which means I only have to
really come in and fight one round but I
want to silence everybody out there that
says I take the easy way out I want to
show them what the champions made out of
I want to do this the hard way I want to
fight beginning to end to be the last
[Applause]
alright I think that's unfair cuz you
definitely earned your first seed so how
about this I'm gonna give you an
advantage if you're really gonna do that
I'm doing it you want to come on up and
accept it's do it I saved this just in
case because one day I did think this
might happen and if it did I wanted to
give you something to anybody who did
this really dan open that up
let's do this Dan and man she got dance
wire oh man this says congratulations
you've earned dibs this advantage gives
you two opportunities on today's movie
fights to call dibs allowing you to pick
your answer before your other
competitors it can be used at any time
before a player has announced their
choice so let's explain what that means
now all the competitors as we get into
this fight we're all prepping they're
they know which fight they're gonna do
but they don't know how far they're
gonna get so they got to prep a lot of
options and they don't know which order
they're gonna be fighting in it's gonna
be random draw I got three numbers and
I'm gonna pick at random now look and
that's when a judge who gets to go first
to be fair for everybody but yes Dan you
just earned dibs that means any fight
you can save it if you feel cocky if
you'd use it right away
at any point you can call dibs and
you'll be able to go first okay any cool
but as long as the other players haven't
already set an answer I mean I have to
call them first any questions guys I'm
so excited I love when we mix it up this
is gonna be an amazing fight we got Dan
we got Scott we got ma oh my goodness is
a fight I wanted to say one quick
announcement this Saturday if you're
watching today on YouTube or if you're
watching to unscrew these plus we're
gonna be a WonderCon in Anaheim all
these pretty much everybody here don't
say it John sorry thank you downtown Los
Angeles 8 p.m. at the Convention Center
if you have passes one Dirk I heard it
sell doubt I apologize but if you can
get in or find a friend's thing tomorrow
we will be there 8 p.m. do not miss us
we're gonna be doing this live it's
gonna be awesome so please stay tuned
and even more important one more
announcement I want to give a word from
our sponsors at audible guys if you
don't know audible is an audible content
service that allows more than 180,000
audio programs from the leading audio
book publishers broadcasters
entertainers magazine newspaper
publishers and everything from Game of
Thrones to the Martian you can get it
all on audible and right now they're
offering our listeners a free 30-day
trial so just go to audible.com slash
movie fights and you can browse the over
180,000 titles that they have and
download a free title so start listening
it's that easy thank you so much audible
audible.com slash movie fights and go
ahead and get your free book thank you
so much audible are you guys ready to do
this where ever
alright I'm randomly picking my numbers
dan Morelle yes go with you first you
will be if I can open this up just opens
killing me number one number one
okay I'm per 1 that means Scot movie
manse you will be number two okay I
think that means Marc you're number
three story this there we go number
three alright that's our order in this
round I guess you don't need to use that
advantage Dan I guess not
alright the question up first from my
Antonio Beckman wants to know which
actor has had the best performance in a
bad movie hmm
now we asked this before in ace in a
speed round it's a good question it's a
good question and we wanted to give this
one a legitimate fight and since we're
doing last fighter stay with some of our
best fighters of all time we brought it
back out dan you're up first what is the
best performance in a bad movie well you
know there were so many to go from and I
went for relatively relatively best
performance in the relatively worst
movie and that's why I chose you and
McGregor in Star Wars Episode three
Revenge of the Sith which is universally
regarded as not a very good movie maybe
the best of the prequels but not a good
movie and the reason that I'm saying
that is throughout all of the prequels
but especially intervention assist it
was almost universally acknowledged that
you and McGregor was far and away the
best part of the movie and his portrayal
of obi-wan Kenobi of all the characters
is the only good one the scene at the
end where he's on the banks of the
volcano and and poor can't act Hayden
don't act Christmas is burning at his
feet one almost suede that movie for me
what almost made that movie worthwhile
is to is his performance just in that
scene as you were my brother Anakin are
you supposed to join them the pain the
anguish in that performance that was the
kind of performance that we needed
across all of those characters in those
prequels and you and McGregor is the
only one that came out of those movies
squeaky-clean he was so popular that
people are still talking about they want
to see a spinoff of you and McGregor's
obi-wan Kenobi and people don't want to
anything to do with the prequels for him
to be that good for people to want to
see more of him says to me that he
transcended that bad movie and gave a
truly great performance alright Scott
what are you picking I'm going with are
you ready for this guy's a truly great
performance in a really really really
bad movie Tom Cruise in Rock of Ages
this is certifiably a bad movie directed
by Adam Shankman he did great with
hairspray a movie that was based on a
Broadway play but he did not do well
with Rock of Ages this movie is super
super cheesy but Tom Cruise as Stacee
Jaxx
he stole the movie he long hair ripped
tattoos on his stomach he sang his own
version of pour some sugar on me and
this is not the first time that Tom
Cruise gave a great performance in a bad
movie he stole cocktail for whatever
that was worth he was actually good in
far and away Tom Cruise there is a
reason why he is still to this day flaws
aside with his personal life the
greatest biggest movie star on the
planet
he can take crap and make it into gold
and even the critics were unanimous in
his praise in praise of him in this
movie CNN said cruise owns Rock of Ages
Rolling Stone magazine said he's
phenomenal cruise plates are for keeps
and Access Hollywood film critic Scott
movie man said this is despite its flaws
cruise fare is the best by far with his
committed and fully toned performance
cruise is always committed in his movies
the move right it was one forty one
percent on Rotten Tomatoes I'm pretty
sure that Revenge of the Sith was a
positive film to call it bad I don't
know if that really works but what's
also great about his performance is he's
channeling his own life he's so famous
that he cannot have a normal life he
embraced it he's playing a fictional
icon and he's a real icon and it's just
it when he is on screen in that movie
it's great when he's not the movie is a
turd whoo all right mark where are you
coming with well at first I was gonna go
with Sigourney Weaver for the alien 3 &
4 but those aren't those are ambitious
don't necessarily work so I focused on
bad and my character our actor for the
best performance and truly bad movie is
Chris Evans and the Fantastic Four
movies because those movies are awful
they're made by the director who brought
us such things as barbershop and
ride-along and they are just aptly
created from every word except for Chris
Evans Chris Evans is the only person who
looks like you have a read of Fantastic
Four comic before he played that movie
he's the only one that has remotely
liked the character he's the only person
on screen
that's awake when you're watching the
movie Chiklis did okay but he was
hamstrung by that horrible Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles reject suit but
Chris Evans was so good at the movie he
captured Johnny Storm if you know the
Jack Kirby Stanley old Fantastic Four
comics that was Johnny this guy that's a
prankster and it just loves life but
when put when put you know in a bad
position he had he rises to the occasion
and he was so good at that that Marvel
took the risk of recasting him as
Captain America because he brought so
much that movie they knew that he was he
had talent he was worth and his Captain
America is even arguably better than the
Human Torch but the Human Torch is the
only thing if you could just cut out
everything else of the movie except for
him those are fantastic four movies are
good solely because of him
Wow okay I need to hear some I love all
of you picked good movies I get why your
picks are right but I got to hear why
the other two aren't right oh go ahead
I'm going I'm going first of all I agree
with that Chris Evans was good in the
fantastic four movies those stars to
Fantastic Four films I think the right
to buy tint story came out in 2005 2007
they are misunderstood because they're
supposed to be lighter films they're
supposed to be family films I think
people want the darker movies or more
serious films but if you look at from
that context they're not bad they're bad
your children or retirement
no no Wow for a family they're horrible
well they're not horrible with you if
you go if you go in understand that they
are family films they're not they're not
great that's not spider-man 2 but hang
on but even if you take even if you take
Chris if you leave take the others out
of the movie it it's I still wouldn't
watch a fantastic one with Chris Evans
he's fine and I agree that he it looks
like he's having fun and he embraced
Johnny Storm the Human Torch because he
was a cocky wiseass but that doesn't
make him miss his performance great it
just makes it better than the others as
for you McGregor
Revenge of the Sith I agree he was the
best thing about that movie thank you
but he is also I know I just gave you a
freaking point but I also think that
first of all with all three of those
films especially the second and the
third as as obi-wan got older you
McGregor's started channeling Alec
Guinness his performances instead of his
performance is still seven making it his
own I still thought you know obi-wan
Kenobi was was based on a pre-existing
character from another film but you said
you're calling him out for channeling
human rater channeling Alec Guinness but
then you said Tom Cruise is playing a
variation of himself in Rock of Ages a
fairy busting out of both sides of your
mouth no I'm not he's not creating
anything original he's just playing a
guy and Rock of Ages arguably you did
pick the worst movie of the movies we've
chosen err yes I would watch that every
day because it would feel like I live to
be a hundred and ninety but saying the
Tom Cruise is the best thing in that
there's a great performance I was like
saying oh I only have skin cancer and
not colorectal cancer well I like his
Manson hit me a couple times on first
things first of all you did not get
one-tenth of the kind of passion that
you McGregor put into sports from Alec
Guinness in the original trilogy he
wasn't doing an Alec Guinness present
for a paycheck Alec Guinness
Alec did sleepwalking a little bit to
the stars
he was the wise old man and he plays the
wise old man well but but you and
McGregor put passion into that character
he put passion into that material which
none of the other actors did and he
actually invested that performance and
like I said Star Wars fans want nothing
to do with the prequels yet they are
100% onboard with seeing more you and
McGregor which to me says that he
transcended the material and was an
actual standout in the film for Chris
Evans is Human Torch he was fine he was
the Ryan Reynolds role I think he could
have put Ryan Reynolds in that role he
could have played it no Sparky I think
if he'd been that memorable they
couldn't have cast him to play Captain
America because he would have been too
memorable as the Human Torch so I think
he blended well I wouldn't say it was an
outstanding performance Tom Cruise in
Rock of Ages I have to tell you I go
ahead ty saw parts of that and I was
just like what is
this time crews doing the Broadway she
was no it was like it was a stunt
casting out why casting because he was
Tom Cruise you don't don't cast movie
stars in those carts he's not a singer
he shouldn't be doing a Broadway movie
Tom Cruise at the AFI there were no
there were none of that none of that was
on the reel he's not a singer but he
learned to sing and he pulled it off
great sorry he was fantastic when he was
on Scientologists what does that got to
do it man he wasn't terrible that
someone was gonna go up with all the
bells ring Scientology into this we're
not talking about his personal life
we're talking about an actor who was
underrated because he is a great-looking
guy and because he makes very very
popular films but no one is more
committed than Tom Cruz when it
comes to his performance hang out on the
side of a friggin airborne cargo jet
it's fine but that doesn't mean that he
was the best lawrence in a bad boy
service for him to do a jukebox musical
yeah jukebox musical that was a risk for
him to be on stage for him to sing that
was a risk I know but that doesn't mean
it's the best performer but he was the
best character in the film he was the
only character that I gave a crap about
and and you can take you can take a
movie just with Chris Evans and
fantastic one and it still wouldn't be a
good film you could put make a movie
just what Tom Cruise has Stacee Jaxx
just what Tom for his face each acts
that would be an outstanding film I
would watch Wow Wow Tom you're paying
him well that Tom Cruise is a great
actor I want to know on one person other
than you and Tom Cruise and Tom Cruise's
accountant who would go see a Tom Cruise
is Stacee Jaxx moving if they came out
just what the Tom Cruise Stacee Jaxx
movie and never did Rock of Ages not
that it would have gotten better reviews
it would have done better at the box
office well of quality either you know
setting box offices oh because it didn't
make money it was a good movie I agree
with that
that's only made 37 million dollars and
that's my favorite movie this brings up
my larger point that was why I think
mine's the best out of the three
nobody's won it's
Chris Evans Human Torch standalone movie
I'm sorry Scott nobody wants a Tom
Cruise Stacee Jaxx movie I don't hear
people talking about or getting excited
about movies with either of your two
actor role I've never heard anyone talk
about the desperate need for our Ewan
McGregor everybody know there is passion
there's fan passion there have been
rumours that this is gonna be one of the
standalone things and fans are excited
to see this because they liked him
because that is the one thing out of
these terrible movies that they enjoyed
and I think that's what it has above you
or two is that they may have blended in
well but mine was an actual stand out
from the bad material great movies
except for the part at the end where his
de facto song he lets burn to death
slowly on the sides of a lava lava river
he was betrayed but also it was the best
scene the heartbreak the anguish they
make shows the performance feel really
interested in what the performance in
that scene just that scene was better
than anything and all of the other
movies combined alright I need because I
gotta wrap this round up final thoughts
we'll start with you mark final what do
you want to end with I just think deal
the only memorable thing from the
fantastic four movies which has been a
cursed franchise is Chris Evans he
captured the character he was playing
completely faithfully and was the only
thing that was alive and energetic and
what you wanted to watch on the screen
Scott final thought okay Chris Evans
memorable not memorable enough Tom
Cruise Taking Chances always taking
chances he played an you know German
officer and Valkyrie I mean he dyed his
hair and collateral he's always looking
for new challenges long hair he sank he
stole the movie he was the best thing
about the film after I saw the film
people ask me what you think I thought
it's up at Tom Cruise is great I
wouldn't be surprised if he got
nominated for it Dan final thought I
think mine's the one that trans to the
material it's the one that people want
to see I think they that Chris Evans
blended in well and wasn't terrible I
think again Tom Cruise
took a risk but I think you're praising
for taking a rest not so much for the
performance mine's the one I think that
people like the most oh I forgot to
introduce them over on the couch at the
beginning show my apologies but Joe star
welcome to the show tickets are the
fact-checking cab Manning Twitter if
you're watching live with us on screen
Aquis plus hashtag movie fights live joe
what'd you think of that round it was a
great round I have some numbers if you'd
like some numbers thrown at let's hear
it let's hurry sir
no from a from the world of facts
Phantom Menace is the lowest rated uh
Rotten Tomatoes score out of this out of
the Star Wars prequels with 56 Rock of
Ages was a 41 the first Fantastic Four
movie 27 percent on Rotten Tomatoes yeah
I'll run how was Revenge of the Sith
well I believe this is critic wise it's
probably in the fresh range but so is
Indiana Jones became at the Crystal
Skull tomato meter is not in the end all
be all of where the movies good or not
but wait a minute if it's a good movie
it's a man you just got to go on forward
to no go and we ask anyone on the street
and we're in Genesis is a good mind like
event it is well if Twitter is the
streets the prequels are striking a hate
nerve and there is a surprising amount
of love for Rock of Ages so they would
never cut to the couch guys how was that
fight alright okay this is this is a
really tough fight this is a really
tough fight legitimately tough do we put
a poll out no pull out on this one okay
if pac-man is listening let's try and
put some polls out so in case I need to
have them all right here's where I came
down to I got to go for the worst one
and I'm just listening to what I heard
I've heard a lot of good points from all
of you but there was one person I heard
defending more and not attacking the
others I also think you went a little
below the belt a couple times which ID I
am sort of dinging him for below the
belt ended up just taking it over the
edge really coupled with the fact that I
think you didn't hit them as hard as I
think they both hit you so sadly I got
into eliminate mark out of the first
round I know you hate me and think
that's the case but I love you and this
is all this before the show
mark has come on Wow here we go Dan and
Scott live another day they cool round
two I mean it next up entering the round
it's JT come on in JT you're the next
fighter on last fighter standing all
right let's talk about the Cuba Gooding
jr. Missile Crisis pulling your number
first are you ready here
JT you are number two for two I'll say
thank you number two Scott moviemax you
will be number I'm not looking number
three
I like that Wow not come tomorrow all
right
rules number one this is random guys
think I'm rigging it I that was totally
random yes I did not look at that ball
skipper turns those yeah round two
alright so we have this way two three
okay
sorry I had to write that down no Dan
and then JT and then Scott all right
this fight this is a fun one was
actually built just for JT round two
which Sylvester Stallone movie would
work better if you replaced him with
Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah what's gonna
be the best movie if you do that
substitution and Dan you're at first
this is legitimately difficult because
there are some sort of a lot of semester
stolen work movies that only work
because Sylvester Stallone to somebody
sir you have to find a movie that
doesn't necessarily work with Sylvester
Stallone in the lead role and there's a
lot of them like cliffhanger even that I
think it would work fine that he's
finding it so I went with a movie that
does not
work that I think Arnold could
absolutely put his twist on so I went
with these cinematic classic known as
stop or my mom will shoot if you haven't
seen stop for my mom will shoot it is a
comedy in the early 90s co-starring
Estelle Getty 92 92 thank you Scott of
Golden Girls Fame keep she plays
filibuster Stallone's mom he's a cop and
it's it's stop or my mom will shoot this
is an atrocious movie and mainly because
of the premise it's called stop her my
mom will shoot and it was already
hamstrung and what is the worst thing
what it was what this diverges to fester
stilling do the worst comedy he's a good
he can be a good dramatic actor he's
good in the Rocky movies he's a good
action star he is not a good comedic
actor so a future Arnold Schwarzenegger
in the lead of that movie all of a
sudden stop her my mom was shoot with
Arnold Schwarzenegger becomes something
that he proved that he was good at doing
in the 80s and 90s which to take which
is to take an outlandish premise and
spin it into something weird
Kindergarten Cop twins him and Danny
DeVito's twin brothers how stupid does
that concept sound but because of Arnold
and because of that weird Arnold
mystique of half laughing at him and
half laughing with him he makes those
movies work so you take that weird
premise you take sly outs to doing
something he's not good at which is
comedy you put Arnold in I think the
movie works better JT what are you
picking so much to say about that picket
um this is tough and I'm gonna steal
your wine there Andy because Stallone
like you said some of the roles he's
just tailored me for so I'm sitting here
I'm like what's the one thing he's not
that very good at comedy yeah but guess
what stop my oh shoot is unsavable in my
eyes and I'll hit that a little bit
sooner but I'm gonna go ahead and pick
the film tango & cash with Kurt Russell
the 80s action movie that has action and
comedy even so the problem with stolen
in that movie is he actually is trying
to be funny and it comes off like he's
trying to be funny he watching her like
how he's trying so hard please that be
able to do it Arnold can do it and I
think he would make that good film a
great film my pick that's right I see
now I like being a nonconformist oh I
can't wait to hear what you said right I
pride myself on being the nonconformist
I
the movie that none of you guys or lady
are going to even guess that I'm gonna
pick because you know what you're taking
movies that are bad that even if they
get replaced by Schwarzenegger is still
probably gonna be bad
I'm going with a film that's actually
really good
but as the saying goes there is always
room for improvement there is always
room for improvement which is why I am
going for the best winner the Best
Picture winner no this is why there's
always room for improvement imagine if
you will a rocky film where I got where
Rocky instead of being you know from
South Philadelphia is actually an
immigrant I break the glass or something
here you know imagine if you all this
guy is fresh off the way we're doing
Rocky one rocky so start from the
beginning go with Rocky one he's fresh
off the boat he comes to America he has
dreams he has goals
hashtag goals I'm going from going on
this cocky balls that's freaking balls
here and he's fresh off the boat he
wants to be a flooded wants to be
somebody he wants to be famous he wants
to realize his dreams he comes here with
nothing but the clothes on his back and
he and even that's tattered so he rises
and nothing at all he has to get his
green card so he could stay in the
country and he wants to be a
prizefighter and he starts with
absolutely nothing is no friends he has
no Mickey his he's you know he gets
Adrian but then
the point the reason that it makes a
good movie better is because it is the
true it is the true year you're laughing
I have a feeling I'm very actually this
is the true definition of the American
dream that's someone from another
country can come here and realize their
dreams and and be the best at it and and
that that is a message that will make
the film more rousing and it will add
another layer by making it more
inspiring and then he he at the end of
the film he gets Adrian but then he dies
not a dry eye in the house rocky the
movie adding another layer into your
films doesn't really change anything he
has a bigger he's bigger straight to
Rocky's bigger battle to fight I'm
telling you but let's go back to an
alternate universe so Arnold
Schwarzenegger is Rocky Balboa JC I
gotta hear your thoughts hey I got it's
so wrong on so many levels that's why I
said you want to make it better it won
Best Picture you don't get better than
that
that's main goal like winning a movie
just because I'm moving what's best
picture doesn't mean it's good hello
crash it's objectively the best it has
Thomas crash the rash is the worst movie
to ever win Best Picture result does not
have the range of acting that Stallone
had at that period Arnold and become
decent actor I would say to Late Late
Late all didn't get good until Creed
Arnold Swisher he would punch krita's
head would explode
he's mr. universe rocky exposed to me
that everyday guy he's the guy in the
bum on the end of the street every time
I'm here with nothing to realize his
dreams but he had to ease it from
another country and he came here annexed
over las history because that is what
the American Dream is all about that
someone from another country could come
here and succeed such a large part of
rock come on it's seven such a large
part of everybody's dancing it's
Philadelphia you're taking Philadelphia
race to Philadelphia this guy take you
there also taking very easy chances here
I'm going out there I'm gonna throw it
I'm not going out there
monkey unconventional pick first of all
let me just stop my mouth shoot is a
horrible premise I agree seals Garros
kindergarten cops those twins yes but
you know what girls Arnold makes their
armor redeems those frills premises
aren't as bad as stop or mom will shoot
a bad premise could tink or movies a
concern yes junior was a horrible
premise and junior was a horrible movie
and I think stop tomorrow I'll shoot no
matter what you play in there is our
home movie there's a scene or slows
wearing a diaper on the side of the
building I don't need to see them with
Arnold Schwarzenegger
sure you did no I don't I don't need to
say that our movie people like that they
like people like supposed to song hey yo
and they like him and Kurt Russell
together which is why I picked it
because it's not about is
ideas dances by flower no no but I'm
saying that my has a lot more room what
is that supposed to be it's supposed to
be a buddy cop action movie that's some
of the movies are supposed to be
franchise then one delete the weapon
thing but honestly it wasn't that good
enough to be that good because Sloan
cannot do comedy Kurt Russell so
charismatic you can put a duck with him
in DL be a great caramel again I think
that Stallone and Kurt Russell is a
solid buddy cop movies guys are good
have been armed Swardson anger the
presence of him in an outlandish premise
makes people want to go see those movies
more so than Stallone because they know
you can't do comedy they want to go see
Arnold being a crazy weird movie with a
crazy weird premise that's the late 80s
Early 90s part of his career that's
where I think you can prove Scott's idea
makes Rocky substantially worse and it's
not improve it in any way shape form it
makes it different anyway what's the
record it is created a different movie
whatever it does not improve rocky there
is no improvement for rocky disagree I
think that it does improve the film I
think you're adding a whole other layer
a whole other dimension that this guy
comes from another country and that he's
got bigger goals and he still realized
them at a layer that is more rousing and
more inspiring there's always room for
improvement I love the original rocky
and I know you do too and I know you do
too yeah this is a chance to do
something that's a little different I
went out there Oh Joe what are they say
on the twin interwebs first of all
they're actually using the hashtag--
here the man tau mostly to ridicule
Scott stop her my mom was shoot has is
winning the poll by far it's a 49% the
other two are into 20s and a lot of
people think Dan is really sexy when
he's angry
okay I think you guys are being harsh I
actually like what said so it came down
that was a great play this over there
look at all right here we go around
three whoa movie superhero would you
most want to be for the for one entire
year if you can be a superhero you can
be anyone but you got to be him for a
whole year
which would you pick Spencer you're
number two okay well Dan's luck
continued we'll find out in a second Dan
number three okay oh all right JT you're
number one actually he's not
all right so here's one okay
I'll rip it have there we go okay one
more so my two now okay I'm so and
that's all over you whenever were you I
was once tonight
so that way now you're three very good
day wait what yep that's how that works
I thought I was too no and he just
called dibs so he rolls down he's now
one he got the advantage by going to the
fight ever I'll go whenever I don't care
I'm here to fight dan dan did you see
Vance hey guys over there in the couches
dude did you like that you think Dan was
allowed to use that good dibs
all right
Danny's use dibs you're up first women
will be super here what you want to be
for one entire year the reason I use
dibs is cuz I spent a long time thinking
about this and there was only one answer
for me and that's Iron Man I cannot
think of another hero that I would want
to be for an entire year other than Iron
Man because if that affected every
answers I'm just curious no great there
you go
no way because number one you don't have
to worry about the whole secret identity
thing you don't have to worry about
hiding who you are everyone knows the
Tony Stark is Iron Man that's great he's
rich he has a nice house he's got Pepper
Potts he's got happy Hogan he's got
friends he gets to hang out with the
Avengers and if you look at it on the
long scale of things the Avengers
themselves some of them get activated a
lot but they don't all get activated a
lot in Iron Men doesn't get activated a
lot so you're fighting maybe two three
times a year tops otherwise you're doing
the military work you're flying around
in the army you get to fly and for me
there's no contest why it's got to be
Iron Man
JT who are you picking this was tough
question the problem I was coming I was
looking all these heroes is there's so
much responsibilities like do I really
want to worry about saving the world
every other month do I really want to
worry about like rich evil villains
couple of plans then you get blamed for
half the time that people hate you yeah
they all know you're Iron Man they hate
you because of it I went with somebody
who I want to be whether he's a hero
he's not a hero and went with Flash
Gordon the quarterback for the New York
Jets so when I'm not saving the universe
which I do I'm actually get to be a
quarterback a starting quarterback the
NFL which is amazing kids are getting to
dreams in one shot and then not only is
he's probably most charismatic hero ever
every person in the Flash Gordon that he
comes across doesn't like him at first
then ends up like
him even the villains daughter falls in
love with him just because he got pure
charisma so I want to be Flash Gordon
savior of the universe Sivir of everyone
everyone fall in love with GTR man so
the question was Spencer yeah who would
you want to be for a year my answer is
anyone I want because I'm picking
mystique no mystique is the shapeshifter
from the x-men and she can become
anybody she wants it appears there's no
limitations to this power so just
imagine the possibilities you can do all
kinds of weird sex stuff just get that
off the bat right away you can make any
celebrity sex tape you want you can find
out what other people think about you
without the burden of telepathy and like
actually getting in people's head you
can impersonate Andy and be like hey Dan
what do you really think about Spencer
you can find out what people really
think about you you can ruin people's
reputations by just becoming them you
could very villain moral grey or she can
help or she can hurt you yes yes offence
for some reason she's still the focus of
these movies but you could do you could
derail Donald Trump's campaign you could
just turn into him and ruin it you could
become a you can impersonate Tony Stark
and get rid of all his dirty arms money
for example you could really it the only
limit is your imagination it's like the
best of being able to be invisible and
it's the best of having unlimited power
and limited fame and prestige and you
can go back to just being yourself but
like a slimmer handsomer more low and
down version when you're bored that is
the one of those devious and yourself
there's nothing heroic about anything
that you just said what superhero do you
want to be Mystique's not a superhero
but I'm not gonna argue that well in the
new movies she started as next man I'm
allowing it she's here let's let's throw
that out but I want to be a hero I don't
want to be someone who's pretending to
be somebody else who doesn't want to be
myself mystique is hates herself that's
why she she loves herself she's blue
when she's proud but but what does she
come around
she can't walk around as herself she
constantly has to hide from everybody
she's constantly hunted mystique some
great inner torture is that she can't be
herself that she has to put on these
false faces that's that's yeah I noticed
evil
misty get it for one fire for one year
yeah you're gonna come out with Leah
Denny crisis you're never gonna feel the
same afterwards you're gonna learn a ton
about what it's like to walk a mile in
someone else's shoes or to walk a mile
in whose shoe shoes do you wanna walk in
anyone it is until somebody else for you
but it are just right not the worst part
of your nature you've been to speak for
five minutes and you're already robbing
people you're taking them out to my
chance so not the best time not so much
to the person you take over it's still
around yes we really sneaky with that
that's fine you don't firm in it then
they're coming after you look I try to
be me well okay enough about mystique
because you guys pick terrible choices
okay I would love to be Iron Man and
just be having a panic attack in the
movie yeah he's dealing with alcohol
he's yelling with like weird battery
daddy issues he has daddy issues if he
has no father that's a huge
responsibility to be in their Avengers
and the CEO of a fortune 500 their
Avengers are copyright to find me you're
stuck there with the hang out with me
Avengers fighting crime all the time if
you skip a day the press is all down
your ass and if you think oh you can be
a Playboy no now you're hooked up with
Pepper Potts yes
yeah you can't ditch her no she's lovely
she's mortified in the brunch you're
crucified what see once again
yeah this is listen I'm getting this
good psychological profile because
you're choosing look at the worst side
of human nature with every one of these
choices it would be so to be a
billionaire superhero in New York City
you are a Ravi on the head that wears a
crown and Tony Stark humor hasn't given
up a giant target on your back the
second you become Tony Stark you are a
public figure and then you can take your
freakin superhero you have an Iron Man
suit in your briefcase you can become
Iron Man whenever you want and then
you're gonna like some kids gonna say I
know what you did in New York and then
tumble back first of all you fixing
their movie
but not humans as God owes them yes
demons and a man - done I am a three
done the iron man that we see now has a
conscience he's comfortable with the
fact that he is a superhero's no
conscience you're carrying a suitcase
with armor in this because someone might
try to kill you at any minute of the day
again there's you forbidding the day and
stuff you're freaking Iron Man you are a
rockstar superhero if you have to go off
to space you have to miss her starts to
get your paychecks doc because
whoever it's no you can't do your cape
on you have to fight in space you can't
go to McDonald's oh my god my earnings
at McDonald's everyone gets Ohio
Minnesota get mobbed then be a terrible
person which is what you are miss Jensen
- temperatures to be steady we're gonna
do is awful either well myself as Iron
Man Ben Ben
I'm gonna do a lot of good I have a list
my behavior was done I'm going to turn
into all the scenery brand in the world
is brewing their reputation you chose a
freaking side Jersey well a gray area
Taylor I want to be myself I want to be
Tony Stark for better or worse I don't
want to be disguising myself as somebody
else because I'm not allowed in public
because I am cast do you wanna be
changing scores amazing I'm saying that
I would rather be myself as Iron Man
than be as Gatson somebody this cannot
be themselves where you both were
tortured by the fact that you are a
mutant and you're constantly hunted I
want to be myself I mistake not mystique
is mystique I wouldn't have a problem
walk around Josh you're heard all the
baggage that comes with my brain or her
head if I heard correctly
correct me if I'm wrong you can make you
what you would choose to everyone anyone
could you're just saying you would be
mystique and still have some expensive
she doesn't get the powers of the people
she becomes that's fine it's great
responsibility go buy a disguise kid you
know yeah baby mystique you can be
regular yeah all right fine I didn't
hear anything why he should lose so I
want final thoughts but go ahead JT and
I better hear some anti-flash final
thoughts I think Iron Man has too much
on his plate I mean look at Civil War
just a trellis the guy is not a good
mood I also hear comes with all these
clips every day you're gonna be up all
night trying to think of good jokes
because they're gonna expecting that
from you and you're so you're so busy
being in the head of the vengers you're
creating new suits you're creating new
ships you're basically the money behind
everything and it's a painting yes look
at the Avengers he was just like I need
to build something's I need to stop
doing this and he built Ultron and
now it feels guilty about that that's a
really bad place to be and I wouldn't
want to be there mystique I don't even
know why you would want to be that
person because cuz you could be anyone
yeah but you could be anyone but that
person's still around you're just
walking around being a fig person which
i think is gonna be horrible for your
psyche and then when the year is over
you're gonna be looking mirror and be
like Who am I why can't just be go back
to doing that it's gonna be like a drug
you're gonna be like damn I wish I could
have that power back but guess what you
only have it for a year I save the
universe you guys might save some
islands you might even really save much
at all I saved the universe I can go to
any galaxy in any moon now be treated
just like I'm treated in America as a
star quarterback take this TV Super Bowl
that's a huge responsibility an NFL
quarterback is one of the most demanding
jobs way more demanding than not after
you saved the universe okay saving the
universe is even worse that's putting
your body and your mind through hell and
you're riding around a space jetski and
getting shot at all the time Flash
Gordon yeah doesn't style it's a theme
song wrapped around a movie I love it
but it's not good and I wasn't on
Flash Gordon he's he's again both of you
guys picked public figures and I don't
want to be someone they're chased around
by the press and as all these
expectations placed on me by the public
that I've saved I want to be whoever I
want to be whenever I want to be that's
the ultimate freedom that's why I chose
mystique
listen Flash Gordon I get it listen who
wouldn't want to be the quarterback for
an NFL team in fighting space it's a
good choice I think this is a battle of
ideology right now and I think that you
agree with me Andy and Spencer I'm sorry
that you're a miserable outcast and you
want to be somebody else over here no
that's what you're saying I have empathy
I want to see what it's like to be
somebody and you want to go screw with
other people for everybody like
yeah I agree with jte is that if you
spend a year not being able to be
yourself have you spent a year as
somebody else you're gonna lose sight of
who you are and after the year is over
you're gonna be you again and you're not
gonna realize who you are and if you
want to go with okay fine my brain is in
Tony Stark's body I would much rather
spend the year inside the head of a
superhero who helps people who spends
his time making the world a better place
who spends his time saving the world
from evil from things that would destroy
it than to pretend to be somebody and
steal some money from in my famous
drinking and panic attack I was I don't
know that's part of that is part of his
character but he is a superhero and he
is a part of the Avengers I would want
to make the world a better place not a
worse place which is what you want to do
well it was fun to see some real stuff
from the honest trailers writers room
good work according to our poll 53%
people want to be Iron Man not as many
people a sexually open as Spencer Kilmer
and only 35 percent 12 percent on Flash
Gordon no other fact checks not enough
those people see Flash Gordon be honest
with the argument about mystique losing
track of who she is nothing like that's
ever happened in the films all the time
you're all being someone else for a year
so the identity crisis argument was hard
for me to swallow because with the
question is who do want to be for a year
so that sort of didn't count for me I
don't think I was as the strongest of
your arguments so I think I just saw so
much passion from two of you and it just
was too strong and I think I honestly
all three of you should win this round
because I think you all gave something I
know your guys are being hard on Spencer
but I can see where he's coming from but
I think ultimately I think you guys were
just being a little harsh on Spencer
because I do think he made some good
points as to why you don't want to be
the hero so much and all that problems
and I think he did give some good
reasons as to why and then I got stuck
with JT's because it's like I only the
quarterback I wanna be the quarterback
it just wasn't saved out of the universe
yeah
I get it but I didn't hear enough more
but yon that is where I was on the fence
that's trying to argue between these two
you gotta get in there you gotta cut him
down I got to go with Spencer and Dan
and I had sorry JT takes Flash Gordon
out I just think it was a very valiant
effort and you did a great job but I
gotta say I think as Hayden is Dan
wasn't Spencer I was listening I think
he did wooden shoes you boys think you
could and you don't have the mental
problem of being the other two just
imagine making out with someone then
turning into Steve Buscemi in the middle
of it for everybody by the way at home
we hate each other we realize but I just
saw too much passion from the tune I
thought both you were giving good
arguments I thought JT was and whether
he got them stuck there having to listen
JT did we did wonderful and good fight
round four that's the only one who
prepared so let's go want to be an
alcoholic with a heart problem round
four next up Hal
screams Oh welcome to the show
Wow welcome to the party pal how how
we've enjoying this one this is an
intense game huh
nobody's leaving it on the floor oh man
is all out there in the ring like it is
insanity all right guys you see headers
from McRae Earth on Twitter we're all
nice move fans here but sometimes ours
before me you just don't like and so
Rima McBrayer this is a rematch actually
I think we've done this before right we
had fights and fights we did this if you
could have punched one actor in the face
who would it be if you could punch one
actor in the face who would it be
now it's time to draw our cards here we
go how rudnick since Europe first we're
gonna call your number you were number
two right Spencer Gilbert Spencer
Gilbert you are number one ready go
that means we're in order hot Dan you
are third unless you decide to Claire
you're dibs nope I will hold on to them
hold on all right here we go pal Rudnick
who are you picking who would you go I'm
number one yes I'm sorry sir what no no
I'm sorry but it's fine
because I think I'm gonna have to pick
someone that's kind of morally
indefensible so I'm afraid to pick it
but I just got to say it because I think
it's the only person that deserves a
punch in the face
it's Jenny McCarthy I think that Jenny
McCarthy is the only actor that and I
apologize in advance I know it's not a
good image for a hitting one but she's
the only actor who has caused material
harm in the world
she's the people make bad movies all the
time not that J McCarthy hasn't made bad
movies she's the only actor that's hurt
your children she's with her anti
vaccination campaigns and her are in her
tirades and her pseudoscience that she
promotes and write books about is
bringing back mumps it's bringing back
scarlet fever it's bring back diseases
that have been extinct for for 50 plus
years so the fact that she is having him
a movie she was in yeah I want to know
she was
Oh can you even
[Music]
[Applause]
you're out of here you're back in Wow
Wow so are we gonna wake back or no
we're not gonna be pick JC you're on a
fly you got to go quick I was sad
winning today Jimmy McCarthy Jenny
McCarthy oh my god right back in this
ham in charge of the show right I'm a
lot of doing I apologize no it's right
in like I don't even think she'd sit in
a movie I gave you a shout alas Janie
you fought valiantly I want to breathe
all right shall we go that's my climbing
present and save no one save JT which
Edgar if you could punch one actor in
the face who would it be
all right I came to say this now the
actor I'm gonna choose as someone I knew
first as an actor do you realize he was
an athlete till later because I loved it
a movies like Naked Gun and the towering
inferno mm-hmm and then I realized the
actor I want to punch in the face as
easily Oh Jay Simpson all right home run
rest in peace the actor that I would
like to punch in the face is Bill Cosby
look at this fist see it now understand
it later
here comes vengeance here comes the five
Infinity stones ready to take back the
night all right Dan Merle who are you
picking what did you think Bill Cosby no
sleeping and exit clarifying the only
one that convinced one would punch
somebody in the face over crimes against
cinema yeah that was not a skip
was not just a punch in the face not so
much out of aggression but to punch
somebody try to punch some sense into
this person and it would be Edward
Norton because Edward Norton had one of
the sweetest sweetheart deals in the
history of the planet he was part of the
MCU he was the Incredible Hulk
and he talked his way out of showing up
for half a movie once every three years
and probably getting paid about forty
million dollars for it
he's a pain in the ass and he's somebody
to punch him in the face and punch some
sense into her weight you want to punch
him in the face over being an artist
no made so many great films God married
her ass on every film that he works on
okay add that to the list of the garden
for that's garden-variety actor pain in
the ass hard on the set and men she did
to himself and then we because of that
we got Mark Ruffalo why things even
better
Hulk my the person I want to punch in
the face is not only a criminal against
cinema with a ghost dad and Leonard part
six and that is not alleged criminal
against cinema that is true check those
on the tomato meter buddy you're gonna
see some low numbers yeah
but he is a criminal against women you
cannot he has assaulted women what a
monster okay
yeah it's a real deal issue yeah it's
not against fun to talk about but if I
was going to punch an actor in the face
oh you better bet it's going to be Bill
Cosby just a random monster listen a
reprehensible monster Jay Simpson
allegedly but I think most people in
this table agree it's almost a fact now
especially because we're watching people
of ours oj that he went and killed two
people got away with it and not only deb
this guy's been just saying we gotta
focus on the movies that wasn't said
that was not my answer
you know what a question yeah that was
not in the question which actor would
you like to punch in the face yeah
Oh J says now let you get away with he
went in our face actor for acting rich
actress in the face alright I'm not
gonna knock it just completely discredit
it but I want you let me know know how I
was thumbing horrible person
oh I gave to I get copyright crimes
against sama oj has been in like the
murder aside it all can be several
reasons several reason um Naked Gun
Capricorn one from the 70s is such a
great adventure movie and OJ is in jail
he's gotten karmically payback he's in
jail for committing an invasion and
trying to steal a back what was his
possessions yeah the only one who has
not been paid back Bill Cosby because
for me to want to punch somebody I have
to really hate it I'm not gonna punch
something because I don't like some of
their movie choices that's why I went
with the most horrible person I can is
that gonna go against me in this
judgment and dry out do I have to fight
some me because of their entertainment
your fighting someone guy stop for
better for worse there's a criminal
justice system number one you're
fighting for someone based off of a
crowd for which they were not I get
murders aside he's great in the movies
first of all he this is not a question
about his movies that we're not say we
had to be cut up here also not only did
this guy get away with it he rubbed in
our faces he came out with a book in
2004 called if I did it he basically
wrote a book saying this is how I would
have committed okay Edward Norton he so
he turns down the Hulk movies he does
not turn down the okay he was pushed out
for being something like Birdman in
which he was such a fair
and easy ones all the time Edward Norton
wasn't such a prima donna he wouldn't be
such a great prima donna and bird man
one of my favorite parts of that venture
that's so not true he was playing
everyone in that movie was playing a
version of themselves Michael Keaton was
playing a version of himself as the
superhero trying to resurrect his past
glories and you see Bill Cosby's a
monster who's the real monster Bill
Cosby where a guy who punches an 85 year
old man in the face Hal Rudnick the
guy's defenseless he punch them in the
face you're probably gonna kill him
speaking of it I'm gonna put money in
the face I'm not gonna punch him in the
face who could probably kill me he's a
gentle be restrained I'm not the one on
trial here bill say no thing Oh Jay had
one more acting role after he was
released from jail in 2006 he did a
short film called the lemon heist where
he plays a jealous boyfriend are you
gonna push him in the face of the lemon
all right it's about the argument yeah
I'm gonna take it based on the argument
we're in debate classic it was
convincing I'm counting the argument so
you each get one last swing at this
maybe here's a stage give me your since
the argument go ahead help
Bill Cosby committed so many crimes
against defenseless people who he
drugged he's also a terrible actor in
cinema it's great economy Oh Jay was a
great actor and he's already got
Columbus in jail Edward Norton he makes
tough choices because he's able to get
he's able to go on and do independent
films which like Birdman which is an
amazing performance based on that
persona all right what's your argument
JT I am saying I want to punch Oh Jay
because not only did he get away with
the murder but he actually went ahead
and rubbed it in our faces releasing a
book called if I did it which was
universally panned most stories wouldn't
even carry it because he basically
walked along saying this is how I killed
it it was a confession book and then he
even took another role his last role in
the lemon heist is a little short film
where he plays a jealous boyfriend who
is almost like suicidal slash crazy they
want Stu
girl he said look it I did it I did it I
just want to punch him square in the
face more than I got I'll pay two
inmates to hold him down in jail while I
punch him in the face
and because he deserves it he has not
guys do that to was doing interviews on
CNN saying oh I didn't do anything I'm
playing golf as I watch those interviews
long ago I'm gonna punch this guy Dan
Europe all right here we go I feel like
I played a totally different game I mean
I don't want to seem like I'm defending
but I have just just as a person who's
interested in the Constitution and what
our legal system rests on I have to
point out that you're both describing
crimes to them for which they have not
yet been convicted I'm not saying they
didn't do that were you judging them as
guilty as guilty secondly they both have
provided a large amount of OJ Simpson
and Bill Cosby before any of this
happened we're both very beloved figures
in the entertainment industry Edward
Norton has been in some good movies he
has a reputation for being a pain in the
ass and he cost himself one of the
sweetest deals in the history of movies
is why I'm not saying he deserves it
because his behavior he deserves because
somebody needs to knock some sense into
this guy because otherwise that's what
he's gonna be in two million dollar
movies he's never gonna get another big
movie he's gonna be out of the business
because over a long enough time line if
you're big enough pain in the ass what
you need not gonna miss your brother Jim
because he didn't accept a blank page
yeah I'm saying no I'm saying that he
that's just true that paychecks job he's
been a good quality from Sandy a host
himself by being a pain in the ass and
costs himself a great deal and again I
was preparing for a way different kind
of argument than either one of these two
movies what happens happen I think this
is a really dark place
I'm on the side of it to be quite frank
he hasn't caught anything if it was
specified but look at Spencer's argument
as well it dealt with you're out of this
Isaac we're sick because we
disagree with OJ know who Joe I only
feel preparin online oh well first of
all you're catching a lot of heat Andy
Jennifer Jenny McCarthy has been in
screen three baseball did not and a baby
franchise could not name them that's
Parrish we were talking about neck
surgery that's fair okay just purely by
the numbers ghost dad is a 7% of
tomatoes 53 women have accused him of
sexual assault the naked gun has an 86
percent on Rotten Tomatoes OJ Simpson
allegedly killed two people through he
threw away that great career Incredible
Hulk 67% of Rotten Tomatoes google was
inconclusive as to whether or not
Everton Norton has murdered anyone I
wish he had at this point all right
there was no bullet put on that one
there was Bill Cosby who's running away
with it all right here's where I gotta
go I'm trying to listen I do have to say
I think Dan at the end did give a very
valiant effort as to why you two I'm
using the civil court system I can't
ignore the fact that you did they were
able to pull that out and sort of go
against the alleged things that you both
are accusing your people of very much
it's a legend according to the course I
can't believe
we gotta follow the court systems the
book said if I had done it that's it so
53:1 it came - so I got and I think damn
did did he was some valley effort so but
I thought that that was my favorite
argument of the whole thing so I Dan
you're safe thank you Wow JT and how it
came down to your basic argument is you
you picked allegedly two awful people
jail by God legit really good make a gun
license I think you lose house stays my
guys a legend but Lord bird did another
he's in G's in jail sorry GT got your
second chance at least I got a an effort
really fun round I guess oh my god
very very JC for coming back good job
all right next up end of the Ring this
is insanity this ring oh I cannot wait
for Mike Carlson to come on up and fight
round five
hashtag Botanica s-- uh-oh he's got he's
got music
the bride his own I love it
[Applause]
just bring that everywhere somebody went
to a kiosk at the mall
hurry up with other rights that's all
right welcome Mike
hello round five welcome to the
Thunderdome what a last round I regret
my decision already
alright the teaser trailer for the Lego
Batman movie was released today and the
movie looks fun I think I actually did
it come out finally did we see it yes
yes I just wrote this before I get a
chance to watch it then Nixon at been an
82 asks what other movie character
deserves its own lego playset and movie
so to be clear they cannot have a
current two lego movie or any if they
have a figure it's okay they excuse me
need a new play set or a new thing we
haven't seen before questions you're at
first Mike Carlson again I'm reading oh
you will be number three dan Merl number
two okay Hal Rudnick that means you're
number one okay all right unless Dan is
using his vantage Hal you're up what
movie character would I want to see a
lego play set and lego movie for it
would be rocky
man what a fun ride that would be then
with Stallone Schwarzenegger um you know
what I'm going out on a limb here and
going for the og Stallone okay
man there are so many possibilities for
Rocky fights for four rocky set pieces
for luck for rocky LEGO sets and so much
fun the training montages if you want to
go him carrying heavy items like the
like the tree like the tree trunk and
rocky for if you want to do the lego
meet Lego treat oh yeah I go tree trunk
do you want to go the Lego Soviet
playset and in a lego movie you could
the beautiful thing about the Batman
movie in the lego universe is it's taken
the
out of the seriousness of Batman a
little bit Will Arnett is having some
damn fun and it's silly let's make fun
of the stuff that we talked about
through the way rocky talks and the
training montages that have become
clichés you can have so much fun with
the crazy stuff that rocky would lift
and do chasing a chicken what is he
gonna chase now in a training montage
with the possibilities of Lego and also
I see with the USA USA a little bit of
Team America World Police fun coming in
to see rocky the way I'm just taking
what he did against Ivan Drago and then
blowing that out of the water man what a
good time a rocky lego movie would be
dan you're up next
well mine was based mainly on the
playset because I think Lego can make
just about anything a fun movie they
made the lego movie they put a lot of
dark to different things in there so I
was thinking like Lego playsets what
would I enjoy because really like oh the
nice Lego playsets generally you put
them together and that's it you put him
together and you can't really they're
gonna fall apart unless you dissimilar
make him into something else so I was
thinking what's a good play set what's a
good movie they'll make a great play set
so I thought Inception how great if
you're gonna buy the inception Lego
playset so you can have different pieces
you can create all different kinds of
worlds all the dream escapes because
Lego is about imagination and the
problem with a lot of the playsets today
is you build one thing and that's it
that's all they are so you have a lego
playset it's on a hinge so you can do
that cool thing where the worlds fold up
you can fold it into a cube you can do
this the sideways thing you can make
different dreamscapes it's a way to have
a movie playset that you can adjust and
actually play with and change and move
around and do bits and pieces of you can
make different designs based on
different dreams different combinations
and then the movie I guess a little it
just visually you know they did some
really fun things in the inception
movies so why not take that with
animation you can do a little bit more
you can do a lot more crazy things you
can go it a lot more than seventh world
you're not as constrained by the budget
but more than anything I would like a
Lego playset that you can actually play
around with instead of like building one
thing and then you put it on the shelf
and you're like huh and that's it you
just look at it okay you'll talk about
the movie we come back Mike alright I
thought about the movie first and then
the playsets came naturally now the lego
movie was very fun because you know it's
a place we can go anywhere we can meet
so many diff
types of characters so I picked a
character who is naturally someone who
goes different places and meets a lot of
interesting people I'm talking about
Lego Forrest Gump okay
Lego Forrest Gump he goes to all of the
major thing major important moments in
American history human history so we get
incredible scenes we get incredible
playsets we get Lego space shuttle
launch okay we get Lego Vietnam we get
Lego Nixon alright and here's the fun
thing about the Lego universe but the
fun thing about the legged universe is
that we're not just sort of beholden to
whatever movie it's moving we can put
everything in we can get a bunch of
different so like okay Forrest Gump he's
in the Whitehouse Nixon is about to
order the Watergate break-in uh uh lego
Darth Maul comes right through that
window cuts Nixon's arm off and it
doesn't happen that's fun that's crazy
alright there in Vietnam they're having
a problem they can't they're just the
enemy has got them cornered well not
when the lego Ninja Turtles show up and
help them alright this is a crazy wild
movie it's gonna be fun that's what we
want from the lego universe that's what
the lego movie taught us if I may I
respect you both as movie fighters but
those are both very bad ideas inception
what kid's gonna want to buy that lego
set what kid gets inception what kid was
even allowed in to see inception and you
can't 13 or older or under I mean yeah a
child who that is Legos largest
demographic is not gonna want to buy
that yeah maybe some scant collectors
but no thing about inception is that it
takes place on these levels in the mind
just oh here's a flat here's a flat
plain and now it folds wow I'm in the
dream for what that doesn't make sense a
Lego set work where's red
here's Rock'em oh no if you build a ring
because there doesn't so here's the
Soviet ring here's the dream how many
reasons are gonna be hangers the tray
here's where he trains here's the Lego
heavy bag here's the rocky set carrying
boulders here there are so many
possibilities Oh
not only does mine have the possibility
of a great movie because rocky could go
USA USA fighting the best fighters from
like North Korea Russia all over but it
would be an awesome place set as well
great more great place one either what
kid is gonna go mommy I got the rocky
diner playset that rod manages or Rob
the gym patreon guy what kid is gonna
say mommy I got the Forrest Gump place
that were jenny has AIDS
hey this is the different universe in
this Lego universe you can just put
Dan's legs back on okay this isn't the
same light universe as the forest go
movie you know I respect our troops I'm
not gonna do something like Lieutenant
Dan take his legs also different you
just said that well I didn't say take
off I said put back on talking about
taking legs I've never heard Michael and
again said oh sorry my good I was gonna
say inception look no kid is gonna be
able to put this thing together they're
gonna be so confused by what's going on
they're not gonna know what to do and
like these are they set pieces it's like
okay they're in a room now it's an
upside-down room no they're on the
street they're in the mountain that's
what I'm saying is you're bringing the
imagination back to Lego you're giving
movie fans a lego places that they can
buy but they don't just have to put it
on a shelf and leave it there and look
at it like with rocky wood and I'll tell
ya two rings and first of all how you
said that a Lego than an obsession lego
movie wouldn't work because it takes
place in the mind right where did the
lego play I say playset and the mind but
you said my movie would not work and I'm
saying that the lego movie already took
place in somebody's mind saying take
that the next step LEGO version takes
place in the mind lego inception movie
would be far too serious for no forever
and children regret Oh wouldn't it would
be no fun because these very overdoes it
would be a very dour no it wouldn't
because they're gonna take that idea and
turn it into a kids movie which is what
Lego does with these franchises if they
make them fun if you just took a regular
Lego set and turned it upside down and
put a top in there you got your
inception place and holes me that was a
regular Lego set I'm saying I'm bringing
imagination back and then Mike your your
Lego force got movement
sounds like Forrest Gump and I am never
watched Forrest Gump and thought
wouldn't be great if Darth Maul jumped
into the scene right now it just seems a
little strange I think you're in the
minority on that one because that's a
thing I've always
dawn and as far as inception is both of
these have sort of normal mundane
scenarios with settings we sort of know
these like yeah you're one can fold over
or you can flip it up but mine literally
you can have so many different like the
marketing team at Lego would be so
excited about this because they could
literally pick anything in human history
all right tell me your movie again why
your movies gonna excite me I've heard
the place that's give me your last pitch
in your movie go ahead my movie is doing
what the lego movies do best it's taking
the piss out of like the way uh you know
the lego movie is doing that to Batman's
character this would have fun with Rocky
and we could travel around and enjoy
amazing limitless training montages if
rocky wanted to go to outer space to
Train if rocky had to fight an outer
space creature that's the level we could
achieve us champion Rocky
going against all the greatest fighters
not only on earth but in the universe
the possibilities are endless that would
be so much fun and completely disagree
there'd be many potential forums and
playsets for the children and different
characters final thoughts in your movie
this is a natural extension of what the
lego movie and the universe is doing
already now it's just got a more
historical bent and we can see anything
from any different time period and it's
something that can be fun with all these
new characters historical characters
mixed with the fictional characters Dan
Lego is about imagination number one
that is their company policy inception
at its core is about the dreamscape is
about imagination I know they're saying
it's too dark but that's what Lego does
they take franchises and they make them
fun and I think that mine offers the
best mix of a potentially fun different
visually invented movie and also a fun
play set whereas their playsets which is
part of the question I think are put
together and put them on a shelf place
that's you can work above mine you can
do different combinations again it's
about imagination what do you think well
I wanted to know what kids would enjoy
inception people under the age of 18 on
IMDB rated at a nine point one out of
ten that's the youngest age range that
give rocky they only rated an eight
point four as far as arguments about
kids being too young to be able to do
complicated lego sets their intermediate
lake
camp is ages K through eight that's the
official intermediate we build robots
and engineering Lego camp Wow
okay I'm really good at this job you're
doing great Joe based on the arguments I
think howls your sounded the boringest
the ring
I think inception we know there's a
dream world I like that Mike went a
little crazy with his with the Darth it
does look like Oh does yes take the fist
we didn't give me enough for how or why
and I think they got you when it's like
oh the witch ring do I get to play with
it didn't sound very fun sorry how
beautiful game though how rattle
applause hell rudnick
tough I apologize call you over there
fighting hard I love you all and I'm so
grateful you all came to do this is
there any extra water over there yes
we'll get you some water I think I'll
find it water for Dan if anybody can
help us alright Alecia Malone bringing
the water
thank you you can just drink it out of
the tub
you don't have a car you never get you a
cup no that's fine you want drink of
this bolt yeah well the numbers are in
there and I have it time I gotta pull
the number Sarah yeah I don't wanna wake
up that's my dish Illya show two cups I
want to come yet well you aren't you a
cop seats in second over Hertz
yeah this is this is us the three
highest seat and enough in the final
three seats I'd like to cut to them fans
enough and he had the fighters on the
couch Bravo you guys seriously the
audience loves you you're gonna be the
jury now is that clear yeah there are
five of you so I'm cutting you because
you're not done help me make this to
verdict okay I want you to listen to
these arguments pay attention no
favorites let's see what happens here
let's make this interesting shall we hey
yeah it's like survivor yeah those
people you just you just murdered there
on the couch damn your number is two
okay Mike your number is 1 lakh Dan
you're number three I mean I'll use this
as my last chance and I'll be three they
show you're number three
all right dan you're up Oh question
sorry if it's all the question of the
audience we'd like you guys to pitch a
massive studio blockbuster but you'd
want to remake as a low-budget indie
this is a fun one take a big high budget
movie 100 million plus tell me how you
would scale it down and make an awesome
low-budget indie Dan and then Mike and
Alicia garden absolutely well my
approach here was I tried to find a
big-budget blockbuster that may have had
a good idea but maybe wasn't executed as
well as it could have been it and I
looked at several and the one that I
ultimately settled on was Prometheus
which had a budget of 120 million
dollars it was hyped as the prequel to
alien and ultimately even though it
wasn't critically ravaged necessarily I
think that you know they're having
trouble getting the sequel off the
ground in the long run I think fans
thought that it was kind of muddled that
it
was a little up its own ass a bit with
the mythology and stuff and it was a bit
disappointing I think you know in the
long run so in my mind I'm thinking of a
movie on the scale of what I'm when I am
most paralleling is a movie like moon
which was made for about five million
dollars maybe a little bit less but I
think that there's a way to take because
really as much as they wanted to say it
was about the mythology what audiences
wanted was an actual some sort of quasi
prequel to alien that might fill in some
gaps and the first alien is such a great
and very claustrophobic movie and aliens
is great but it is not that at all it is
very big-budget Jim Cameron movie alien
3 was a David Fincher movie 4 was a bit
of a mess and Prometheus was just a big
Bridget's portal so I think if you can
take Prometheus take the idea for
Prometheus which is to fill in some of
the gaps behind if you want to start
some new alien movies but also introduce
reintroduce audiences again to what they
loved about alien in the first place if
you scale it way down and you actually
make it kind of a smaller scale alien
movie similar to the first one but with
some new twists to the mythology I think
it would be a really fun effective movie
and I think it would make a lot of money
particularly if you make it with an
indie mindset for you know 5 million or
less all right Mike what are you pickin
alright I hope this is I googled
blockbusters so I hope this is a
blockbuster I am picking okay I took a
movie that I think would be more
interesting with a smaller budget which
is why I picked it the Truman Show okay
because if we think about it The Truman
Show to me isn't that interesting okay
this guy lives in a beautiful town it's
amazing they've given him like
everything they want they have actresses
that are paid to like paid to like him
this guy doesn't have it that rough what
does the low-budget Truman Show look
like okay so the move inside the movie
they have a low budget for The Truman
Show it's basically about a guy in an
apartment in Orange County California
who is being spied on without his
knowledge and he's slowly being driven
insane this is a movie that we can all
relate to this is something that we can
understand this is a real-life guy okay
and they don't have like fancy union
actors to come around to pretend that
they're people in its life they have non
actors who aren't really pulling it off
very much and he's like starting to get
weird and starting to not know what's
happening he's finding spy cameras
everywhere in his apartment not know
what's going on there are people
following him he is freaked out and by
the end of this movie he has lost his
mind
this is gonna be a weird dark indie
movie which is the kind of indie movie I
like all right Alicia are you pickin
well the kind of indie movie I like I
love sci-fi and I think indie films can
do sci-fi really well so I picked a film
that didn't do well as a blockbuster but
I thought had a really interesting idea
amongst all the mess and that is
terminated Genesis so terminate Genesis
I think you'll agree is not the best
film but inside Terminator Genisys the
thing that I really liked and found
interesting was the idea of Genesis we
know that Genisys is Skynet it's this
operating system but the thing that's
interesting is the fact that everybody's
excited for it there are lines around
the block people are counting down to
Genesis it's going to make their life so
much easier
little do they know it's going to be
evil now the thing that I think an indie
can do really well is look at a big
theme but do it in a really personal way
and so I would love if a terminator
genisys Indy could look at both the
tower obsess we are culturally with
technology and how it's taking over our
lives and also with the idea of
singularity the point that's might be
coming soon when robots and machines or
stuff that we create start creating
their own robots and machines I thought
that was really interesting
but unfortunately inside the blockbuster
world 150 million dollar budget of
tomato Genesis so many cooks in the
kitchen it got watered down by all the
plot holes in the exposition and the big
set pieces and the crazy special effects
so you can still do some action you can
still do special effects but I would
give Terminator Genisys and X Mack and I
type feel to it all right I would wonder
it like what Arnold be in this or would
it be nice because I think that that's
an interesting space but you mentioned
ex machina and I think that shows like
black mirror I kind of exploring that
now I don't know why you'd have to put a
terminator title on it way I mean I
think it's it's a terminator title
because of Skynet which is really
interesting
and I think even more prevalent today
then in 1984 and now I mean I just got a
car which speaks to me in theory so I
feel like a robot overlord but it could
turn evil you know I think it's
something that we're all kind of
thinking about yeah sure sure no
absolutely I'm just my pushback would be
like I'm not exactly sure why that would
have to be Terminator Genisys and not
just I think that we've seen several
movies and some TV shows that are
operating in that space right now and
then as far as Truman Show goes I III
don't know what the budget was on The
Truman Show I've never considered a
blockbuster I'm not gonna quibble with
that but my main thing is I just I just
love the Truman Show I think it's a
fantastic movie I think the acting is
great in it and I would hate to take
that property which is very positive and
I have a very warm feeling about and
kind of turned it into a very negative
thing that I just don't I don't think
it's necessary I think it's a great
movie I don't know why a remake would be
well if we're talking about necessary
like we don't need the 9th movie and the
Terminator franchise or the 10th movie
and the Alien franchise like these are
two things that have been like driven
into the ground so but also like it when
we're talking about franchises like
these things now have an expectation on
them both of them like we're talking
about an indie we're not talking about
50 million dollar movie we're talking
about like a 5 million dollar movie so
like people are gonna go thinking these
are alien and Terminator movie and it's
gonna be really bare-bones really low
budget that the first Terminator movie
was made for 6.4 million dollars and the
first Alien movie was made for about 11
million dollars I believe so they are
technically Indies well yeah a little
bit but also that's true but I think
that my main thing is like I'll agree
with with Mike on the terminator thing
which is that people are gonna go
expecting to see a Terminator movie or
terminator you can still add terminators
I mean ex machina won the Oscar for
visual effects and it was made for 15
million so you can do great special
effects with Indies it doesn't mean that
you only have a human drama when you
talk about Indies this is gonna have
terminators in it too the thing I love
Truman Show and I think Truman Show was
ahead of its time and actually if you
read what it now it still works and some
days I walk around wondering if I'm in
Truman Show you know I think that it's
that kind of obsession that culture that
we have of being the star of our own
lives and
and Prometheus I just don't know what it
has to say about today I think indie
films particularly sci-fi films are able
to explore what is going on today going
on right now and that's why Genesis to
me sound like a really interesting idea
Truman Show at the time though was very
like as much as it's sort of it was
precursor to like all these crazy
reality TV things like now we're living
in it now we're in the swamp The Truman
Show this in the Truman Show is going to
be what we're doing now like we're in
the bottom of the barrel we all can
periscope on our phones and II was doing
it before the show we're all crazy now
well possibly I'm totally trusting
ourselves but so then wouldn't the jig
be out pretty soon well this movie is
gonna be so dark that's what I that's
what I'm trying to say with that movie
it's not gonna be sort of this
idealistic all what a nice like it is
obviously still torturing a guy by
putting them in a fake but it's a nice
place like now we were in such it so on
the swamp of reality television and all
everyone wanting to be celebrity like
let's make a movie that represents that
sure but I mean you're both describing
films that are kind of commentary on
modern technology which I again I think
we have so many of and and why I'm
circling back to prometheus is that for
an entire generation of people there
hasn't been a good alien movie made in
30 years maybe more and I think that if
you take that core concept which is what
turned so many people on in the
beginning which is that kind of one
person against that primal force of
nature and I think it would be
refreshing if you do it on a smaller
scale because if you limit the scope you
are able to spend a lot less money on
sets and a lot less money on big space
battles and big fake heads and big fake
ships you're able to spend what money
you have on actual good practical
creature effects and make a really great
throwback horror movie it would also get
people back on board with the franchise
the Terminator Genisys I don't think
people are want to see a smaller scale
version and plus I wonder if you're
gonna have terminators and all this how
much on an indie budget are you gonna be
able to do but keep it scaled down
enough to per people to like it yeah you
can do a lot definitely and the thing is
like I think it's different to something
like it's not gonna like age of Ultron
in that you know people are excited for
it it's something that people actually
want in their lives
I thought that's what made interesting
in the Terminator Genisys world but
Prometheus also explores technology and
also explores robots and what makes
someone human and what makes them robots
with Michael Fassbender's character and
I didn't think Prometheus really added
anything new to the franchise and and
aliens and alien still stands up alien
and aliens still stand up today when you
watch them because especially the first
one because it was so self-contained but
I think Terminator Genisys because of
the world we live in now it's it's
interesting to look at verses 1984
terminator and I'm with with both these
two and like there was 6 million 10
million like after inflation these are
still probably like 30 to 40 million
dollar movies like when we're saying
pure Indy like I think that both these
movies though people are gonna come to
expect a certain amount of the thing
they like from them so it's like going
if we made an Iron Man Indy right now
for 5 million dollars he's not gonna be
in that suit very much he's gonna be
like in a suit towards the end people
are gonna look out the window and go oh
there's Iron Man he's out the window
always coming back like you know a lot
of stuff you won't be able to see that
stuff that we expect from these things I
think has an Indy feel and that's really
interesting I would love to say any
comic book may be done in that way
something more relatable and I think if
you make a great movie that defies
expectation if you make an alien movie
on that budget which again I think it's
possible if you if you go to the
hallmarks of the original I think that
is possible on a small scale budget if
you defy those expectations I think
people that will find that refreshing
again the tree was saying the same The
Truman Show concept I just think is so
radically different from the original
and also again the technology angle for
me it's like there's just being
saturated with so many movies and TVs
about technology and the dangers of
technology even the terminators movies
were about the danger of technologies
like guy said something people are
worried about which is interesting to
capitalize right but it would just be
one in another series and I think that
this prometheus is a way to revisit the
franchise to make the kind of
small-scale horror movies that you don't
see a lot of anymore all I'm saying I
think the two of the both of these
arguments are sort of like trying to
remake the first movie this is a totally
different movie taking it in a very
different direction okay final thought
two different direction I mean it sounds
like a completely different movie to
trim and show and the idea is to remake
a blockbuster Jo oh let's see here let's
take a look at budgets Terminator
Genisys was made for 155 million
Prometheus for 130 Truman Show for 60
million I did not start writing comedy
because I'm good at manipulating numbers
in terms that's close in terms of a
cultural zeitgeist for our Genesis
versus Truman Show four out of five
people reportedly don't use Siri
periscope has ten million registered
users
alright guys in the couch I hope you
were listening were you listening let's
cut to a mellow guys are you listening
listening don't vote you bet if you were
listening who's got the mic there grab
the mic and I want to chime in who do
you think gave the best argument over
there I really the movie I would want to
see most is the stripped-down version of
The Truman Show based on the arguments
okay I actually what want to go with the
stripped-down version to Terminator
Genisys you sold me on the ex machina
pitch low-budget film 15 million won
Oscar for special effects you do that
I agree with that I think the first
Terminator was a low-budget film if I
got into this round Terminator 2 was the
film I would have remade as a low-budget
film
I think there's stuff that could be done
that's very interesting
Truman Show being remade as a low-budget
film we we can watch all that stuff for
free now we're living and I think might
defeat it himself by saying that and
prometheus I don't know how you make
that good if you have no money because
it wasn't good with any money change it
for the guy in Orange County being
stalked by strangers on there I think is
AKB Mike Carlson biopic
that's I'm out then JT I'm down he is
yes at least you really guy with X
macchia and I feel like you said the
first Terminator was such a little bunch
of film it's proven that it could work
so she kind of got me with that high
well here's how I'm gonna go you might
be going but just wait until it is
official Joe in her poll yeah there was
a poll this was actually our tightest
poll that we had The Truman Show has
lead with 37 percent followed by
Prometheus followed by Terminator
Genisys alright so here's where we stand
I think Alicia you did win yes Leisha
won it came down to Dan and Mike I'm
taking all that so what was the vote
over they gave all kinds of votes cuz if
they're picking their favorite she's not
picking the word it didn't all think
yeah but no I think Prometheus doesn't
help but I'm still struggling with what
yeah which one should go yes yes let's
go around one more time quickly this
isn't gonna define it but I'm just
really clear who gave the worst argument
well who sucks the most
who gave the worst argument I'm least
interested in the term in the Truman
Show one but I actually think Dan gave
the weakest argument Scott I wasn't
crazy about The Truman Show it's not
even a blockbuster no Spencer tomato
Terminator was a great low-budget movie
but I never want to relive anything
Genesis related and I don't think Alicia
sold me on three split for me it's
Truman Show I feel like the budget being
smaller wouldn't affect the original
film that much how I might want to see
least and I think as Lee's potential is
prometheus
so that really and the poll who's
leading the pulse the poll is the Truman
Show 37% Prometheus 34 Terminator
Genisys 29
alright here's where it stands sorry I
don't really think about it I'm lying I
mean I can really guy I have the truth
here's the truth I got it I'm started to
delay this because I know I gotta go
what are you so what'd you write I wrote
yikes I think my composing concert OCU
and I'm like actually really tough
because I want to make the fair choice
cuz its life like go with Dan they're
gonna say oh you just pick Dan if I go
with Mike than the hard you go with Mike
so I got it really Dean here what what
you said I heard you I heard you both
hitting Truman Show a little harder I
was stuck because I don't see where it's
a remake in a way and I think they sort
of I was so and I'm not I'm just talking
out loud I was slow because I feel like
I've seen it so many more times where I
where I get stuck and I think with
Prometheus it was sort of the same
reason why terminator could work it was
you guys sort of fell in the same camp
so that's where I was sort of leaning
the poles aren't advice of enough to go
I got to go with my gut so I got us a
Truman Show is out
just barely based on that point I've I
just think it's not even it's an
interesting movie but I feel like it
might have to be The Truman Show so
that's where I'm stuck and that's what I
heard and I think that's what happens
Mike though brought it all right
that means we took Dan off you made it
all the way I've known that rocky not
believe me and they're gonna think I
favor did you I didn't I'm really
listening the argument and I that stuck
on me of true it was a weird choice from
the beginning yes a good pitch but I
think you guys took a little bit more of
a daring choices Joe alright yes I
you're gonna help me pay attention and
some of the speed around questions and
all you guys at home because I might be
chimed in on you Joe on the argument I'm
warning you I got you sir guys in the
couch we're going to speed round I'm
gonna may ask you for universal choices
here to help me get through this Alicia
and Dan you're in the final five points
are all gone you're starting with zero
the first to win these the best-of-five
here is the winner of we made again
Oh try this before we go though I got to
thank our sponsors once again inaudible
guys sorry bear with me guys did you
know that audible is the leading content
service includes more than 180,000
titles including audio books publishers
broadcasters entertainers magazines
newspapers there's a really good book
out there coming from our own kidnap
sock Star Wars lost stars by Claudia
gray that expands the entire Canon of
the original trilliant point of view can
highly recommends it I would suggest you
check it out too you can get that and so
many other books there at audible
offering and they are offering our
listeners a 30-day free trial so just go
to audible.com slash movie fights browse
over 180,000 audio programs download a
free title and start listening it's that
easy thank you so much audible
audible.com slash movie fights alright
we're here in the final five questions
here we go you bet speed round music
hopefully he has the speed round music
no it's better without Vicki okay there
we go
we're gonna start with a bargain bin
picture this is submitted from Jay a
totally for don't post it yet you should
have the bargain bin picture ready I'll
tell you when submitted by Jay telly for
you can see two movies on screen you're
gonna tell me which movie you'd pick
first yeah I'm not gonna say them out
loud because I don't want to hear myself
over your pick so yeah go ahead show the
picture all right I heard damn with
Batman alicia has got Superman
alright guys everyone on the couch
everyone please pay attention here we go
phones away Pat man versus Superman I
heard Batman first Dan 15 seconds Joe
here we go Batman in Batman Returns in
that to pecker really - interesting
great Tim Burton dark Batman films I
like both of them Batman Forever more of
a mixed bag but the Riddler is great in
it this guy great villains Batman and
Robin is a turd Superman one is great
Superman two mixed bag three and four
terrible already went through all of
them Alicia it's your turn
okay Superman is iconic and it's so
great to see Christopher Reeve in that
iconic role we haven't had a great fun
Superman
since Christopher Reeve was particularly
now with a Man of Steel and Batman
versus Superman now is all dark and grim
I enjoy the original Superman films
Batman used to have terrible choices
there
Superman three and four to the four
seconds Superman ready yes Superman
three and four are two of the worst
superhero films ever made Batman and
Robin is at least entertainingly bad to
watch five seconds for Leisha held on
Joe catches up and go Batman and Robin
is one of the worst superhero films I've
ever made it's laughable it's cliched
it's ridiculous
all right on the couch quick votes I
want to hand off who who made the better
argument here better argument pass
around quickly dan dan one for Dan Dan
one for Dan like they both made the same
points pal I agree that would Spencer
they made the same points but at least I
got Alicia got specific with that
Christopher Reeve yeah I agree the
Christopher Reeve really took it over
from Shirley she gets the points don't
disagree gonna wanted to go with them on
that one here we go number two this was
submitted by Travis Hill Travis of H on
Twitter best Zack Snyder movie 300
Watchmen 300 vs. watchman Dan you were a
first everybody listening times ready
clock starts when you start Dan 300 is
actually an enjoyable movie it's a
faithful adaptation of the comic it
doesn't change anything which is why
it's a good Zack Snyder movie he had the
world map laid out port Watchmen is a
very disappointing adaptation of one of
the best pieces of literature written in
the 20th century
all right Alicia 15 seconds when you
start I can't coming from it from
someone who hasn't read The Watchmen
comic book or the graphic novel I found
Watchmen really interesting dark
fascinating characters the visuals were
like evened out with the characters at
300 is all visual spectacle and all man
and not that interesting five second
bottle Dan 300 is an entertaining visual
spectacles Watchmen is a slog even if
you haven't read it it's dark it's
depressing
five seconds Alicia I like to watch man
ivory watched it several times
I have never seen 300 again and 300 is
not right guys in the couch I hope you
were listening tight let's pass that mic
around I'm keeping the scores 300 or
watchman Alisha Watchmen is a much
better film than 300 yeah that's Alicia
Watchmen is the Citizen Kane I gotta say
Alicia cuz her argument was all about
the movie and Dan made too many appeals
to the comic book hey Alicia Wow
alright how I gotta go Dan because I
think the watchman's beauty is the
faithful adaptation and I Alicia didn't
grab that JT hi Oh Alisa I think she
gave more facts why Watchmen works and
Dan just kind of said 300 entertaining
but I think Alisa just gave more facts I
gotta agree with him Dan I heard a
little bit more why you got a little too
much stuck in the comics it was one
point but I got to go with them Alicia
you're up to number three that means I
stopped doing this one right I mean I
have to win all three here we go
they gotta win all three Dan yeah it's
been done before here we go number three
worst Mark Wahlberg movie Planet of the
Apes 2001 worst Mark Wahlberg movie
[Music]
I'm gonna go with the other guys wow
they didn't go transformers alright fun
plan th was the other guys Dan go ahead
Planet of the Apes is one of the worst
remakes one of the worst summer movies
I've ever seen it is depressing I never
wanted to see it again we had to do it
for honest trailers and I hated watching
it again it is unpleasant the other guys
is a funny comedy I like the other guys
it's not a bad movie all right Alicia 15
seconds we start well the other guys
didn't show you what Mark Wahlberg can
do I just thought it was a stupid film
very forgettable human Will Ferrell were
funny but Will Ferrell overshadow qiyam
Planet of the Apes at least was kind of
entertaining I think I played this one
five seconds Dan
I love comedic walk Mark Wahlberg Andy
is funny in that movie planted the eggs
is a terrible terrible terrible terrible
movie I know one should watch it five
seconds Alicia
the other guys is just upset and silly
and I should have chosen transphobic all
right do you wanna couch one overrule I
think Dan won that one put
wholeheartedly yeah I'm also a contender
the happening yeah all right Dan's on
the board unless I hear an overrule I
think we're all hopefully we better all
agree all right number four you're still
in there Dan mm-hmm who will win an
Oscar first TFA or Kristen Wiig whoo dan
pick Tina Fey and Alicia pretty Kristen
Wiig I didn't hear it did someone here
who was first dan I think yep I heard
you talk a great Dan you're up first 15
seconds when you start the sad truth of
the Oscars is a daya reticent to
recognize comedic performances and I
think that was what sets Kristen wigs
wheelhouse Tina Fey has the trump card
she is also a writer she has written
Emmy nominated in Emmy winning scripts
and I could see her winning an Oscar for
writing a script Alicia I could see
Kristen Wiig winning an Oscar facting
she's actually gone to some dark places
she's done some dramas she has a whole
depth to her comedy and tragedy so
closely aligned and she's got both sides
of the coin within half all right five
seconds Dan I just feel like Kristen
Wiig has that thing that Jim Carrey
can't overcome which is that she starred
as a comedic actor they love to give
comedic writing five seconds Alicia I
don't think they love to give comedic
writing Awards and I don't think Tina
Fey would win for her writing she's
great in that TV seriously well I want
to go to Cashman I'm kind of frustrated
correct me if I'm wrong Kristen Wiig
wrote bridesmaids Ronnie Stanwyck was
nominated for Co screenwriting rights
made so the faculty didn't pull
that Jimmy is disturbing so I gotta go
with damn but I want to go to couch does
anyone disagree based on those arguments
um well but besides the fact that Sheila
did she dropped that part the fact of
the matter is that Tina Fey's not a good
actress that Kristen Wiig is a versatile
actress Tina Fey's a personality actress
so technically I would vote for alicia
even though she dropped that one fact
but it's go for as well because Kristen
Wiig has gone to some pretty dark places
yeah but some of them didn't hear that
though guys base your flat based on the
argument
okay that's right here that Spencer yeah
I guess I'm siding with Alisha to dance
thing that Tina Fey could win for
writing doesn't hold water because they
don't nominate comedy scripts either
it's all drama and you said funny to us
so bridesmaids was nominated nah maybe
it's who won annoyed Spencer how I agree
with Mike all right all ignoring the
fact that she didn't call out the
writing well I was saying she will win
an Oscar dan doesn't call it out either
he didn't know that she was about
Kristin was nominated for writing a
comedy either why would you reveal that
he doesn't want to prove that point he
would like point of the fact that that
was the main argument if she's gonna win
it but wouldn't he say well she has not
won it so if she won't win it again no
that's what he would say when did what
is she I miss how did I miss it what did
you say about the dark actors yeah I
said she's gone to some dark places
she's done some dramas she's got facets
and I've said that Jim Carrey hasn't
been able to overcome that either
there's still a bias
oh man I'm frustrated all right Joe what
did you think I've got to go with simply
on the power of her doing some dark
places she brought up her dramatic indie
cred so I've got to go with Alicia come
on Andy come on I gotta go with Alicia
based on everyone's unanimous
her defenses I'm so hung up on the fact
that you didn't get the writing but it's
true as long as you went there I agree
and everyone heard it I got I can't
ignore that leave him alone
[Applause]
the showstopper now what you'll see here
is a lock on the showstopper now this
only Ken and I have the code now the way
to showstopper works you can bring after
today let me just read this right by
winning this prize you'll have the right
to challenge the champion during any
movie fights broadcast within the next
calendar year locked inside our five
speed round questions once cashed in the
questions will be revealed a speed round
will start immediately and the title
will be on the line whether the champion
agrees or not nice it can only be cashed
in on a movie fights after today you
can't do it right now where the current
champion is present that means like you
must align with Kenan I and as long as
the movie fight challenger is present on
a show you will be able to come walk in
surprised that fighter they will not
know and you will be able to challenge
them immediately at any point during
that show for the belts yay the champion
must accept the challenge me champion
must accept the challenge and again like
I said five speed round questions are
locked in that showstopper we will
unlock them and read them aloud and see
if you win so you have an immediate fast
pass to win the championship belt Oh
Alicia oh that's a game-changer on my
right Thanks to everyone who retweeted
me because that's why it was easy I see
this situation cash cash it in what do I
think we have it the showstopper things
I totally lost my inhale
in there damn it now you've wanted the
showstopper cash-in I'm so excited for
that system Dan if you keep the belt I
keep it we're gonna have another belt
fight something soon if you keep it at
least you can challenge it you use some
strategy when you want to catch that it
can't wait
congratulations Felicia congratulations
everyone the couch what an amazing game
thank you thanks so much for sticking
around and doing it I think we're gonna
try and do a quick after the fights with
whoever can stick around in five minutes
thank you so much for watching on quick
sorry
don't forget WonderCon will be there I
want to thank everyone really fast
obviously Alicia below gnarly at least
you're alone on Twitter thank you dan
Merle and Merle Dan Mike Carlson over
there on the couch at fat carlson
correct Scott mance movie Mantz the
movie manse right movie manse of Twitter
Spencer Gilbert sir GJ Gilbert mark and
Draco at mark and Draco on Twitter pal
Rudnick and Hal Rudnick on canal Rudnick
and JT in the booth at JT e what is it
smash smash 80 i nylon Andy Andy signal
on Twitter Instagram also I'm just on
Facebook's go find me on pub with my
foot public face before do some live
stuff from there and fun stuff so find
me for you
a fan Joe star on the couch thank you so
much for doing amazing job on
fact-checking we will see you next on
after the fight thank you so much what
show we got to do this again someday the
comments below bye bye every podcast we
put on YouTube comes with this kick-ass
graphic listing all the topics your
favorite screen junkies podcasters are
talking about if you click the topics
you can skip around and choose your own
podcast battle royale go ahead try them
all if you haven't already subscribe to
screen junkies on youtube to join us for
future fights or if you prefer to listen
on itunes click the logo to download an
audio version
you